why are you here
we don't have anywhere to sleep tonight
so you're homeless i had a home and then
we left it
[Music]
do you want to call the cops now it's
not too late and say what that he didn't
hit me
we need to get you off the streets
there's beds at the domestic violence
shelter
you're here
you can breathe
i'm alex i'm trying to piece together
how i got here
my mom is undiagnosed bipolar and she's
mia right now
i got into college
i wanted to be a writer but i got
pregnant
now i'm a single mom
young bro no you got a problem with
background check no this is a trial oh
i'm starting today that's good news
ain't it bro girl
we compost the bin is labeled calm post
can you read or should i show you i can
read
oh
[Music]
i don't think i can do this
so quit
i can't quit
i live for my daughter
they can kick dirt in your face
alex i haven't had a drink today you
don't leave a good man when he's trying
and they hate the way you shine before
they bite they bark i pay all the bills
let you hang out with my friends i do
everything for you before they hit you
they hit near you
[Music]
and hide how much it hurt it grows like
mold
ms russell did you file a police report
on the night you left no you can't take
a child away like that it's grounds for
losing custody this is an emergency you
are an emergency
[Music]
don't ever let anybody take advantage of
you
you will never ever control me again
when i think about the house i want for
my daughter and me
it's not big and full of stuff
our space is a home because we love each
other
this place
safe
it's good for everybody
today we honor a part of us
a fallen campus colony
our home is gone we are all we have
yeah i know
we're working to stop the monsters
and to save people from turning in the
monsters
none of us will be safe as long as this
exists in the world
bang
hear him change the game
so we
change how we play
is why you is that they're the reason
the only family we got is dead
[Music]
one wrong move and it's over
[Music]
why we killed thousands of people why
don't you tell us
if history
is then how did we we're gonna find out
what the crm is up to
and then we're gonna burn this face to
the ground
[Music]
[Music]
it takes facing the end
you know it's gonna be okay
[Music]
and as we pray for the souls we've lost
stay vigilant
and may god bless us all
[Music]
hey
i know that the civic republic is the
last light of the world
my purpose is to create a new era on
this planet
hope we get to catch up while i'm here
[Music]
you don't have to protect me
protect yourself
leave get away from us don't understand
you're gonna go off and be a famous
writer someday
going to follow his brother and go to
some fancy college
jamal
go figure things out and get out
with this life
it's my destiny my family crest is and
will always be a gang sign
it's too late no it's not
[Music]
oh
it's okay
let it out
i'm not crying
gary is cutting onions
[Music]
there is an assault on the truth
not your truth or my truth
but that's right
every case every defendant that was put
away with evidence from our labs has
been called into question our life's
work is alive you either made an error
or you were a party to criminal
malfeasance what we're really talking
about is my lab's reputation
welcome to 2021 a lot of careful
criminals out there we do get the
occasional [ __ ] what do we do now what
we always do jim
follow the evidence
do you think i could persuade you to
come back to csi
[Music]
you do this job long enough the things
we see
when you want to scream
where do you go
my experience science will tell us if
how things look
is how they really are
in the end arlen the truth emerges
he's seriously posting from campus i'm
not worried it's like you want to get
shut down
hey baby
school is back in session
and you know what that means
so am i
this week i'll be taking down four of
bayview's biggest defenders
let's just say
i've got enough dirt to bury him
your obsession with other people's lives
is pathetic
nobody at this school would call out for
anything if it weren't for me
simon
jesus he's allergic anything he's
breathing you want to help
detective wheeler has a couple questions
wasn't it an accident
they think one of us did it without
simon you get to be valedictorian you're
accusing me now i know that i don't know
you
[Music]
we need to work together now and why
should we trust you
so you guys have no secrets
i've got too much on the line
tell them the truth it's not going to
change anything
everybody here hated him
but who also hated us
[Applause]
[Music]
what is a secret we're literally killing
four
[Music]
here you are the afterlife we are ghosts
and now you can enjoy all the rewards
eternity has to offer
but what's this that's the horse's
carriage uh oh it's the living wow okay
this is huge and it's all ours oh
they're moving into your house you light
this stuff and it wards off evil spirits
does that work they're over here
and they're there libertines gosh darn
it now they're everywhere why why
trash can right there
what's a soul to do
well why not haunt them out oh after all
you're ghosts yeah here are three
surefire steps to a successful haunting
step one
voices from the beyond
when you sing the living can hear you i
get it i'll hum something scary frighten
them with your mournful
song got the stereo working cool
haunting is hard step two
walk through them when you do they can
feel the essence of you
and that's mighty
spooky babe nice try that was you it
smells like a fart when the living walk
through you dysentery with no party
step three telekinetics yes moving
things in the physical world may require
a lot of effort
no sorry hold on you got it you got it
but if you can do it
nothing is scarier
[Music]
[Applause]
for further tips on how to properly
haunt a home she can see us
[Applause]
watch ghosts coming october 7th on cbs
everyone has a halloween they'll always
remember
and this
is jake's
jake you into vintage no i'm in the
retro oh what's the difference about 10
bucks
fair enough
look at that someone took the butcher
knife
hi
i'm chuckie
wanna play
[Music]
jake
are you okay i can't stand this out of
blood
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh no jake that isn't quite right
what happened to you jake
you used to have friends
don't forget your boy toy
okay
it's contagious isn't it laughing at
people
well guess what [ __ ] now the joke's
on you
hi
i'm chuck
and i'm your friend to the end
what did you do
[Applause]
mommy says real killing is bad yeah well
mommy's full of [ __ ]
look around you it's the world series of
slaughter
everywhere jake wheeler goes death seems
to follow
creepy doll just creeps me the hell out
it's kill or be killed everybody's gotta
choose what's going on with you
you wouldn't believe me if i told you
chucky
he's gone
dude you have a secret style problem if
you only knew
[Music]
hey kid
i'm gonna go kill your sister
wanna come are you sleepy
you snooze you lose
[Music]
i know
most people don't think about us up
there in the mountains
many of my patients are minors it's
dangerous work and
they carry the burden of building this
nation on their backs
their own pain
these people my people
trusted me
i can't believe how many of them are
good
now began looking at something that
could be big oxycontin
purdue pharma they've been marketing the
drug as something that's non-addictive
when it clearly is all your doctors are
gonna be asking how is this even
possible your most effective talking
point are these magic words
less than one percent less than one
percent less than one less than one told
me that less than one percent would
become addicted
foxy cotton does what i think it can
[Music]
it could soon become purdue's first
billion dollar drug
purdue continues to lie about the drug
safety
doctors the patients and the fda
we have a major case here
addiction rates overdoses and crime
are on the rise across the country
because of this drug
i think maybe the medicine
might be just a tad more addictive than
you said
i can't live like this anymore
our community is ground zero for
national catastrophe
purdue will not move unless we punch
hard
[Music]
this is not our fault these people want
to be addicted
i want top executives to feel some pain
it's crucial they understand we've
created the greatest painkiller in the
history of human civilization
[Music]
i think i can make this the biggest drug
in the
[Music]
world so what's next batwoman we find
that case of batman trophies before
anyone else does
[Music]
curiouser and curious sir
[Music]
testing one two three
gather round friends
it's a lovely afternoon
for tea
by the order of the mayor's office you
will be remanded in the supervised
custody if you attempt to escape you
will spend the remainder of your life in
solitary confinement any questions yes
does this wreck my ensemble
four down i'm gonna sell out there a lot
my team gets a bead on the batman trophy
and then you use your creepy brain to
figure out where it is
matt is a hat
that woman new episodes premiere october
13th free next day only on the cw app
you've been drinking tonight
what about drugs
medications you're on look i saw her
fall she was out on the bluff she went
straight out to the edge
[Music]
that wasn't her
percy didn't do this maybe i made a
mistake
one of the lobstermen saw percy drive by
after your 9-1-1 call
somebody has a hold on here if she's
alive she could be anywhere
she was scared that some guy was after
her
you're the only innocent person in this
house
you lied to me
you need to let this go
what is it about percy
we're the same you and i
we're both killed team
[Music]
they're out there and they will find us
we are sitting ducks for the akaya
they're afraid meaning they may even
want to talk
what we are about to do is not without
risk
but the reward isn't expressed to get
back to earth
let's go
home we can't fight
sure as hell can't run
we've got to figure out what the acai
want
i augmented her with a cayenne code and
created an alien ai
why haven't the akaya taken us out the
only way to know for sure is to ask them
they want to talk peace nico
with you
i'm doing the right thing right
communicating with you kyah
all we can do is move forward
we jump back to earth now they'll be
right on our tails and we'll be right
back where we started humankind has a
choice
accept and die
resist
and endure
i cannot continue to play defense
against a species that destroys planets
on the whim we can take your entire crew
back to earth back to your family where
you belong
and in return
how many more of our friends have to die
for this mission everyone find somewhere
sturdy and strap in i promise you we're
going to make it
there is no future for us in the acaia
[Music]
this is a warning
for what this fight is going to
[Music]
until all your cost are dead
[Music]
you should have left when you had the
chance
i think hope's gonna die
legacies new episodes premiere thursday
october 14th pre-next day only on the cw
app
in my history of scared
this
is the most scared i've ever been
congratulations dad it's a boy
i've always believed in the one
but being your dad is changing me
[Music]
for you
i'd move to some soulless suburb come
latter with us
for you i'd marry the monster
your mother love
what could go wrong
we both have done bad things i wanted to
move here so that we could start now
we are just a nice normal neighbors next
door we are a team
the best team
oh no this is bad
so now i have you
things will be different this time
something's going on you're always
distracted are you okay you look paler
than usual
[Music]
i think we need to go to couples therapy
this came sooner than expected
marriage isn't really built for secrets
there's no such thing as privacy in
madre linda
you obsessed with her
why don't you love me anymore
oh he's plotting something i can feel it
why does everybody think i'm impulsive
you are not making me kill anyone
neither one of you is gonna kill your
spouse you're many things but you are
not murderers
i never thought to wonder
what happens after boy gets girl
we're a team okay
[Music]
till death do us part
[Music]
this is life
if it wasn't me it would have been
someone else
[Music]
you know how impossible it is to be your
sister
graduation
am i right
[Music]
this graduation party is economy
i can't believe you
i'm sorry
it's brutal out here someone must have
said something did you say something
[Music]
it was an accident
no one will really know what we did
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you look tired
i didn't sleep home you still having
nightmares about renee
frankie's been out of prison a month and
a half and we haven't done [ __ ] i just
want to make things right
i need my job back because of you and
quavo's cousins are back on the street
selling that [ __ ] killing kids
still playing cop i'm not playing
anymore
there's a new product on the street
we need to find out where it's coming
from
and we need to shut it down
put me in coach the shit's about to get
real
here i come
you can't hide who's the head [ __ ] in
charge me
you got balls girl
you need to watch your back with those
two they straight up vipers
you're gonna see rafael while you're
here i wasn't planning on it it's good
to see you vlogger
i'm the cop bray
i got the badge what do you got
just doing what i got to do
why do you have to be the one to go
after
i don't know i just do
i dropped a bomb
the whole world was watching for my next
move you're the number one trending
topic ahead of tater tots and
the pope followed you oh wow okay no
this is not the is this the real no no i
don't think this is hope
my family have disappeared i need to
know where everyone is and what
everyone's thinking
there he is the little man who started
this big war
right now i'm the real you sure and i'm
the real you
you sound deranged
as i understand it you want to take down
your dad without implicating yourself
correct and without damaging the company
to the extent that you lose control at
your shareholder meeting do you have an
actual case ken yes i can kill him
is he gonna watch could we make a note
in the minutes that he's watching us
there's blood in the water sharks are
coming bruhl is a company we're gonna
lose a [ __ ] company today
investigation's looking pretty bad i'm
focused on not going to jail logan says
we have to take these
cyanide pills
it's a mint you doofus
no one's on my side in this i need you
to protect me pinky
if we don't beef up soon i think we end
up someone's lunch
when will your father die uh with due
respect no no no obviously hugely
looking forward to my father dying right
what does this end this friction
i thought my family was [ __ ] up this
is next level
roman is a knucklehead shiv is a fake
and kenny is screwy i've seen more than
any of them
this life is not for everyone
it's a number on a piece of paper
it's a fight for a knife in the mud
i'm a good guy
i'm better than you
or [ __ ] beast them we'll go full
[ __ ] beast
[Music]
uh
ah
i'm done
listening to you morgan
everyone has everyone tried it your way
and look what happened
[Music]
face the truth morgan
you failed
and now
it's my turn
i'm gonna do what you couldn't i'm gonna
rebuild the world i'm gonna help
everyone that you let down
all while you watch from the outside
you should rebuild the world victor you
should help people but if i hear that is
not what you're doing if i hear that
you've heard anybody that i care about i
swear to god
i will come for you victor
and i will do what you tried to do to me
on that submarine
only i will miss
alicia
she'll find this place
she'll get through to you no she won't
she won't have anything to do with me
after this
this bitter
[Music]
my fellow citizens of the world
what i have to say to you
is not something i was ever prepared to
say
as many of you know by now we are
suffering from inexplicable and
seemingly unrelated incidents
[Music]
ranging from power outages
[Music]
we now believe these incidents are not
unrelated
but in fact connected
is not of our earth
[Applause]
[Music]
was that your only encounter no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we might be all that stands between life
as we know it and the end of all
existence
the world wants to test us
to see if it can break us
not today
this
bitter may not be so
bitter
[Applause]
[Music]
this world has so much potential
to be
reborn and consumed
to be ruled
it's time to finish
what i started
you ready
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh issa you were so simple then
i just want to be drama free and happy
i keep frightening everybody like i'm
not scared about what's next for me but
i'm terrified
so what am i supposed to do now
[Music]
maybe there's a little voice in your
head that's telling you that you're not
done that's you
you're the voice in the back of my head
it's evenly hehehe
[Music]
senior year wasn't supposed to go like
this
i moved back here
got named an all-american
and i got the girl
and then um
what's going on it's cool mo had a gun
i don't know maybe people like us ain't
supposed to have it all you tried to
hold me down so i became a soldier i
can't leave the people i have left you
were way too smart to throw away a
scholarship
there's no way cooper let you set aside
your dreams
she ain't here to say it someone said
foreign
i don't know maybe there's something out
there that scares you at some point i
got to take a leap and find out right
on me we missing a member of this family
who's dealing with the tragedy that man
carried us here damn near on his back
we still have a championship game to win
you're giving me everything finish it's
keeping me
tequila
[Music]
congratulations
thanks
[Music]
uh bullet rocks
this is the story of marcus watkins
you